嘿，今天要分享的案例，讓我覺得蠻有意思的。你有沒有想過，只靠一個簡單的玩具，竟然能賣出上億個？
上億個？這麼誇張？現在這個時代，不是都得靠什麼高科技、AI、元宇宙才能成功嗎？一個玩具怎麼可能做到？
其實我一開始也不太看好，但聽完故事會覺得好像沒那麼難想像。這個玩具叫做 Clickeez，長得像機械鍵盤的按鍵，重點是有「喀嚓」的按壓聲，就像那種紓壓小物。
喔，所以它就是一個進階版的指尖陀螺？這種東西不是紅一陣子就沒了嗎？怎麼可能賣到上億？而且這種簡單產品，進入門檻很低吧？競爭會不會很激烈？
這點其實不容易做到。根據報導，這個 Clickeez 是玩具公司 Goliath 推出的。他們從有想法到產品上市，只花了一年時間。你知道一般玩具開發週期是多久嗎？大概要 18 到 21 個月。
一年就上市？這速度確實是快，但速度快不代表能賣得好啊。他們具體怎麼做的？有什麼關鍵數字或人物嗎？
當然有。主導這個專案的是 Brian Weiss，他是 Goliath 北美區的總裁。他從小就在玩具產業長大，對市場嗅覺很敏銳。他們觀察到成人圈很流行客製化機械鍵盤，就想辦法把這個概念轉化成給小孩的玩具。
把成人的喜好轉化成小孩的玩具？這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字。Clickeez 從 2025 年年中上市到現在，已經賣出超過 1,000 萬個，而且預計今年底會賣超過 1 億個。這銷量確實驚人。
對吧！而且他們是怎麼做到的？Brian Weiss 提到，他們觀察到辦公室裡設計師和遊戲玩家很喜歡鍵盤客製化，結合了這種感官上的「喀嚓」聲音和收藏的樂趣。他覺得如果能把這兩者結合，就會是一個很棒的收藏品。
聽起來就是一個抓準市場趨勢，然後快速執行、搶佔先機的故事。但問題來了，這種「爆款」商品，通常生命週期會不會很短？這個模式撐得久嗎？
他們的策略其實蠻聰明的。Clickeez 不只是一個單純的按鍵，每個按鍵上還有不同的角色臉孔，可以堆疊、串成鑰匙圈。這就增加了收藏和客製化的樂趣，有點像集卡片的概念。
所以它不是一次性消費，而是透過「收藏」來延長產品生命週期。這就解釋了為什麼會賣這麼多。那如果是創業者或中小企業主，可以從這裡學到什麼？
我覺得最重要的一點是，不一定非要高科技才能成功。有時候，一個簡單但精準抓住人心的產品，結合快速執行和有效傳播，就能創造巨大的商業價值。
嗯，有點像在既有市場裡找到一個新的切入點，然後快速把它做出來。那一般上班族呢？這個概念能帶入自己的工作或生活嗎？
我覺得可以。很多時候，我們可能想把事情做得非常複雜，想追求所謂的「創新」。但這個案例提醒我們，從生活中那些看似微不足道，但能讓人感到愉悅或滿足的小細節入手，去觀察、去思考，也許就能找到獨特的價值。
比如，把一些日常工作流程裡，讓人覺得有點「卡卡」或「不舒服」的地方，像 Clickeez 一樣，把它變成一種有樂趣、有收藏價值的小習慣？
沒錯，或者觀察身邊同事或朋友，他們習慣做什麼、喜歡什麼，然後把這些「小點子」跟自己的工作或專案結合。不一定是大發明，但能改善體驗，就能創造價值。
我猜啦，這不只是做玩具，做任何產品或服務，其實都適用。找到那種能讓消費者「會心一笑」的點。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候簡單的快樂，才是最難能可貴的。